it is the end of the ice age and death
for man and I'm Swift and often over the
next five minutes you'll experience the
harshest time in the history of mankind
this is how far cry does the Stone Age
you are to car a seasoned warrior of the
Windsor tribe known as the beastmaster
to survive you must embark on a savage
adventure filled with brutal weapons
warring tribes and mystical journeys to
Carr and his people are at the very
bottom of the food chain threatened by
man and beast alike to overcome his many
foes Takhar has powerful weaponry at his
disposal durable clubs versatile Spears
and various forms of the deadly bow and
arrow
to create the foundation of his arsenal
he can craft even deadlier weapons using
rare materials found throughout the
world the double bow and arrow takes out
two enemies at once and the addition of
fire can turn a cave bear into a flaming
ball of destruction around Berserker
bombs turn enemies against each other
while be bombs create lethal
distractions
slings traps and other weapons round out
two cars equipment affording him
unlimited creativity in how he
approaches each threat
especially when confronted with
fortresses and strongholds brimming with
dangerous warriors Thakkar has his own
special mastery with the ability to tame
and command wild beasts he ascends from
prey to predator his constant our
companion provides many benefits from
aerial scouting to executing enemies and
other animals provide a variety of
useful abilities with badgers terrifying
other wildlife great cats stealthily
eliminating enemies and bears causing
mayhem in combat some animals can also
be ridden granting 2-car mobility in
battle and across this great expanse of
land
in order to save mankind the car will
have to conquer other tribes led by the
maniacal ie the OODA or vicious cave
Lars that attack of our size allowed for
them hunting man is they different than
hunting beasts meat is meat the only
people the odom hate more than the
window by the asilah and the merciless
leader battery worshipers of the Sun God
the izella enslaved their victims and
terrify pose with their mastery of fire
Wildlife is not the only thing that's
plentiful in this world lush landscape
provides the materials to carnies to
craft his wide assortment of tools a
gifted hunter Takhar can read every
facet of his environment in order to
rebuild his village you'll need to use
these talents to find rescue and protect
lost members of the winter tribe to
unlock the full potential of his village
thakkar must acquire the resources
necessary to build proper shelters newly
recruited specialists help advance
various techniques and a larger
population allows for the spiritual
journeys that might just save the wooja
from extinction
nightfall poses many new dangers even
for a beast master as there's nothing
more terrifying than being haunted in
the dark
with human survival hanging in the
balance and his life in constant peril
the car must fight against all odds to
rise above extinction
or Cry primal
Oh
Reserve now available February 23rd